hi guys I know here on ya Gwinnett's
that we enjoy a good horror game so how
about we play a game called never mind
never mind seems really really cool
because basically it uses biofeedback
algorithm to sense how stressed and
scared you are the more stress than
scared to become the scarier the game
gets now the thing with this game is
that it works best when you play it with
something netqin sense your fear be that
heart rate monitors sensors or eye
tracking so we're going to do it today
with the Toby eye tracker and see what
happens well it know that I'm scared
apparently with eye tracking you get AI
controlled interactions if you close
your eyes you can pause the game I'll
play some nice soothing music for you
and apparently there's surprise I
tracking features in every level if you
notice any let me in the comments below
because knowing me I probably won't even
know it's because I was so scared of the
game
okay so just like shelter I can look at
the corners and it kind of tilts it that
way just a little bit more where are we
in school breakthrough award the newest
algea institute okay then you Estelle
jeans
touch anywhere on the screen hello dr.
our facial recognition centers detect
that you must be newest algiers newest
nearer proba welcome to the team we're
nearer probers now guys Oh return I
think I thought I pause because I looked
at you and not this switch okay I'm
gonna have to look in this street The
Scream the experience ahead will contain
intense and disturbing scenes and
situations these scenarios may trigger
adverse reactions in participants who
may be especially sensitive to
narratives and imagery involvement
psychological trauma bring it on by
proceeding forward you take full
responsibility for what you may
experience ahead do you agree I already
clicked agree that see that is just that
was just a force of habit I already
clicked the agree to agree box without
reading please provide the following
information my first name is young man
my last name is X we will connect this
information against our records to
complete the identity dr. yang man x
this is so cool you're free to enter go
go go have a wonderful day thank you I'm
a doctor can't run oh that's weird
fancy fancy open the door
hi oh you do not look nice look at this
guy looks so shady I'm sure he's lovely
there seven years at new associate
Institute I bet these are the games
developers aren't they for our bubbly
should go toilet choose toilet no not
allow it's not as good toilet okay what
about here sisters stuff oh that's my
English my office this is pretty dr. yag
Mannix let's go into our office mmm why
have i got a locked door in my office
welcome dr. X dr. eggs i am dr. X is
just using my surname um should we look
at the handbook yeah I go on I want to
know what how to new rope rope narrow
protein is a cutting-edge technique that
allows uniquely trained medical
professionals newer probers to venture
into the subconscious minds of their
clients these clients are individuals
who experience psychological traumas and
have since buried the memories of the
traumatic event deep inside their mind
turning into forgotten memories that
haunted the clients in devastating ways
these lost memories can be recovered in
neuro probing and with the trauma
remembered the newest alger institute
can further assist the client in
confronting his or her past and begin
the path to recovery select appliance
are there different different plans from
excuse no I have to do this okay
interesting assimilated minds gave
constructed by newest alger to help with
new employee orientation okay oh oh
that's when the door opens let's have a
look at our office the mindscape knows
calm stress fear anxiety okay so it goes
all staticy when it's bad trauma it can
happen to anyone at any time
me so pretty
well it's been way too nice and pretty
for a horror game I think this is the
horror game it's like a scary ish game I
like this about mental health stuff
because this game is supposed to kind of
help you understand your emotions a bit
more on how to calm yourself down when
you're feeling anxious and stuff like
that the interest in is a simulated
mindscape created by the newest Archer
Institute to ensure new new euro bizarre
fully prepared physically manifest
almost unbearable for and for my family
nothing has helped I guess that's why
I'm here so if I just talked about my
troubles you'll be able to use it later
to help with
procedure seems how to believe that
you're the experts and I think many of
my issues started when I was young so
why don't we start with my childhood
days yes I was raised in a lovely
cottage in oil Germany we didn't have
much but my twin sister and our father
died got by there was actually a Great
Famine for much of my early childhood
and often we went without food i had
many happy moments with my family but
the darkest times began when my father
remarried my stepmother always resented
my sister we didn't like her much either
to be honest God she was [ __ ] sometimes
she would take my sister and me out for
long walks in the forest and then she'd
hurry home my sister and I couldn't keep
up and we'd often get lost we learned to
leave a trail of whatever we could find
on those works to help us get home I
guess in some ways our stepmother helped
us become resourceful my sister is a
real fighter if the kind of woman any
girl or boy could look up she volunteers
to work with various youth organizations
now enough about okay what else maybe I
should talk about my feelings yes
you may not believe but I've always
struggled with various eating disorders
and anxiety around food eating anything
rich makes me feel scared
anxious no cake it's how to describe my
sister has actually experienced similar
issues and it has worsened for us both
as we've gotten all where they Hansel
and Gretel's not norm why is it taking
me so long scar we've said it is not
about this past they've determined that
our issues may be trauma related but
have yet to help us sort out the
underlying source they have yet to fix
us
that's why we're here
alright don't why dr. X is here to fix
you whoa what why am I tiny I'm a tiny
little person I'm a tiny little person
while neural protein you will encounter
objects that look like photographs this
is how your consciousness interprets the
concrete memory moments it finds within
the client psyche typically there are
about 10 of these memory photos found in
each cycle the mind can hold on the hay
so antiquated system you'll find that
half of these photos present an actual
moment relating to the trauma the other
half tend to be false memories created
by the clients conscious mind okay den
ultimate when you acknowledge a memory
photo it will surface more prominently
in the client psyche often he or she
will experience and breakthroughs at
this moment that breakthrough is what
every neuro prober lives for and is the
key to the client finally being able to
work towards true recovery day brats go
away love your stepmom oh she seems like
a wonderful woman oh here we go did that
just run me a pair was that with that
for the whole time we mean remember me
we'd often eat rabbits tease
very specific maybe the most important
thing as a no improvement is find and
acknowledge these how I get it the
photos are very impulsive while neural
code make a left click motion to engage
with it holding up when you are done you
can make a left click motion again
my sister saved me from becoming dinner
yeah it is Hansel and Gretel try to stay
calm peaceful he says that you need to
stay calm you can don't come then you'll
find the subconscious will call itself
to then the game starts getting freaky
if you freak out basically these are the
little breadcrumbs oh there's a door up
there
here is an example of an especially
buried memory some details of a given
trauma can be especially tenacious but
by gently and cleverly listening to the
clues the mine gives you you will find
all you need to work through it just
think of it as a puzzle for you to solve
when you focus on these puzzles make a
right click motion if you need to break
your concentration
and these just swap the pebbles around
Oh put it in this mouth gotcha simple
puzzle master the birds would never sing
for us
oh schizer what the hell that baby
wasn't there a second ago are we going
up here ok this weird stuff happening
Malibu ok it went from really nice to
poopy very quickly wasn't expecting that
all right creepy ass baby oh you can
pick it up do you want to take the knife
with you I guess we're just simple oh my
god they just okay whatever it's fine
now should I what should I look okay
they just falling down it's fine a
terrible fire burned our home down
that's not good so apparently if I get
too freaked out I can close my eyes nope
nothing ah got ya ok so a little pause
it pauses the game when you close your
eyes and also supposed to have little
surprises that happen in each level
apparently using a the eye tracker so I
wonder if you'll find out what any of
the surprises up ah that's nice here
again since kids gone got all the photos
is that although no I so go through here
this 10 isn't that so I've got five new
fiber month
stay calm even in the face of danger
remember when I mentioned that the
client subconsciousness can I'm afraid
my don't some especially and you play
this you must be I'm not gonna get
freaked out
there is weird noises happening okay
maybe it's me I think I'm making the
Restless actually maybe I don't know
there's definitely someone following me
but I'm not gonna turn around just in
case carrying an object you can even
pick up and walk around with some
objects to do so interact with it and
then start walking while holding on to
you do you want dinner little bears bad
food oh okay
what the hell is that noise sounds like
someone's paying an awful flute really
bad recorder what's this this isn't it
it is a really bad recorder cuz i used
to be a recorder when I was a kid really
badly so I know what it sounds like oh
no don't insecticide its way hey Pig
that wasn't a big to begin with okay
forget that never happened let's give
the bunny some food
did they want the food I don't even know
just seems to make things worse for me
cool hate the dolls Oh
what is this what animal is that not one
of those sphynx cats oh it's snowing
that's pretty this record it just makes
me laugh not really doing much me and
being scared
frog it's my favorite so far
okay we don't even have a flashlight now
so I know there's something behind me
freak me out like that getting so
disoriented Oh picture wait I haven't
been biting them the house was a trap
children will be cooked and easier
they're definitely Hansel and Gretel I
knew him they given each other a fist
bump
oh what a pretty moon still be creepy if
there was like um someone stood there in
the mist from where you just came how
does that work how does that work that's
not white architecture
guess we're in someone's mind though it
so it doesn't really matter does it I
forget this just doing this forever do I
need to jump off the bridge do I need to
be brave and just jump should I do that
what do you guys think showed us jump
rips my carry-on I don't know here we go
okay if I had jumped I would have just
died in someone's head Oh can I oh okay
no ow
I was supposed to do here scary scary
candy canes gonna eat them eat them eat
them if you heat them some we can get
through oh did I today as she just will
pass that no I don't think I did she
would take us to the forest to die but
we would leave a trail to find their way
back home one time we got very lost just
like I am right now I wish I could run
all right yes candy canes are gone let's
continue carry on being brave mushrooms
when your consciousness is in another
sub consciousness your psyches will
inevitably intermingle just as the
clients mind can affect you you will see
parts of yourself reflected in the mind
of the client Oh what at red light ha
and tread carefully its flesh that's
pretty disgusting I didn't expect to see
that hmm ok
I will tread carefully
what's that
those are mini mini breads and a sheep
sheep
yeah what the bloody hell ah I thought
it was a face and I thought those were
boobs like I actually thought they were
boobs scary stitched up boobs ok it was
carry on why are all the mushrooms
stitched up on the top it's creepy I
guess that's why
squirrel that was what that animal was I
didn't know what it was mm-hmm not the
lollipop dr. lollipop sort of bugs Cole
at norris toldja we take great measures
to ensure our over safety as best we can
no however you are about to proceed
through a highly dangerous area that you
must face alone we can do that price but
I don't leave our homes too volatile you
will be automatically removed from this
area of the mind and how I can do since
we don't need EMTs fine use this as an
opportunity to collect yourself when
you're ready things are gonna become a
trainer you left off okay battle the
darkness and chaos taking
I was bitten by an animal in my sleep
all right guys we're gonna follow the
trail of cookies this is when things get
dark when you have to walk on giant
chocolate chip cookies all right kids
bones oh oh gosh oh my god let's just
walk and just hope that we go into my
way yeah no we totally died but surely I
can just be able to walk straight
through here like no no no nope I don't
know I think I'm there yet I'm undoing
yes yes yes ah what is this I don't look
oh ok it was the worst birthday ever i'm
in i'm in the oven i'm in the oven
hey high five was I supposed to do that
yeah I grabbed his hand and he pulled me
into here oh it was the worst birthday
ever
definitely if you oppose into a furnace
you don't rub it
this is the end I think I've got one
more picture to find
ok
No
my dog
it's okay oh this is the door just
looking at here's the last picture with
a mini piano cookie we were last but we
found a house that looked nice yeah that
was it wasn't a nice house again I'm
gonna put it in the right order now yea
though I am so tiny my stepmother hated
my twin sister means that are we first
oh the one about she would take us to
the woods and the to die yeah that's the
one we were lost but we found a house it
looked nice full of sweets but then the
house was a trap children would be
cooked and eaten there at all what's up
my sister save me from becoming dinner I
think it's this one and then that think
do we do it did we save the person are
they cured now oh my god
it's all rushing back
it's so awful and I don't want to
remember but it's okay handful I now
know the face of my demon my sister and
I we were taken out into the woods by my
stepmother for one of it nighttime walks
we'd usually find our way back by
leaving a trail of whatever we could
grab before the walk their marbles
pieces of paper even papers however one
night she took us deep deep into the
woods we brought some bread to leave a
trail of crumbs but what the forest
creatures must have even we were lost so
roast we tried to find our way back but
it was so dark and we were in a very
strange part of the woods we were lost
for days hungry and tired we finally
found a house and was so hopeful that
someone might be able to help us
that house though that house was no
ordinary house she looked like candy and
there was something off about it we
shouldn't have gone in vance but why
wouldn't you go and it's full of candy
it was a prison for lost children like
us there was a woman in the house who
would fatten her prisoners up and try to
eat them and that was going to be our
fate but your sis is badass she tricked
me into getting close to the oven and
before I knew it I was inside if it
weren't for my clever sister Gretl
pulling me out in time I would have been
burned alive and don't forget yes and
found our way home after that things
started to get better our offer step
mother passed away and my family came
into some wealth
I guess
I guess we just forgot about those
events I mean how could you live with
those images and memories inside your
mind
then again they were always there the
old woman still torturing us beyond
memory beyond time
my way by Fanning you up I can now
confront my past confront this troll
thank you it's okay it is better to know
than not dr. X at your service overall
plane never mind that the Toby I tracker
was an interesting experience to say the
least it was weird having the camera
move of my eyes and having it know how
kind of jittery I'm getting so how
scared I was ghazi it was pretty awesome
let me know what you guys thought of it
in the comments below do you think the
Toby eye tracker helped make this more
immersive if you want to get your hands
on a Toby I chucker to play games like
never mind shelter or even games like
Assassin's Creed do they've got a whole
bunch on there check out the description
below for a link where you can buy it
with thirty percent off using the coupon
code my legs as always I hope you have a
lovely day or evening by that this weird
blob that you see going around the
screen is not normally part of the game
that is actually the toby I tracker
telling me that is seeing my eyes and
it's crazy it's really strange but we'll
see what kind of changes this makes
apparently it allows us to look at enemy